l'icône touch vous l'avez là devant vous
présentait donc c'est une table
numérique tactile interactive itinérante
aussi à la disposition des publics on
met quoi disposition des ressources
iconographiques et pour cela on a dû
développer une solution logicielle donc
avec un centre de culture scientifique à
bordeaux cap sciences and start up bin
lab pour créer une solution logicielle
open source est vraiment une volonté de
travailler sur des contenus sur des
besoins spécifiques
avec bien évidemment le souci de mettre
ses contenus à la disposition du public
le public le plus large d'une part et
d'autre part les publics scolaires
les objectifs sont assez simple on
pouvait lire
je n'ai c'est avant tout une itinérance
des outils vous voyez nous allons
vraiment aller à la rencontre de nos
publics dans les établissements
scolaires c'est ensuite encourager une
nouvelle forme d'appropriation des
images par de nouveaux usages numériques
parce que les jeunes sont en demande
justement donc c'est pouvoir d'y aller
dialoguer autour de l'image pour voir
interagir au niveau de l'image
et puis à la fin c'est d'aider
sacraliser un peu aussi parce que des
images les photographies les huiles sur
toile et peinture vous n'y avez pas
forcément accès et pas forcément la
possibilité de toucher or là avec ce
type d'outil c'est vraiment un avantage
vous pouvez toucher interagir
télécharger ces images pour les
retrouver chez vous vous faire des
activités en classe avec vos enseignants
au départ on voulait que cet outil soit
accessible à des jeunes publics puissent
leur parler qu'ils puissent se retrouver
sur des images c'est publics sont eux
mêmes des producteurs de contenu
maintenant c'est à dire qu'ils ont créé
un atelier avec leurs enseignants c'est
la preuve que ça marche c'est la preuve
qu'ils ont adopté ce nouvel outil
numérique cette nouvelle offre
culturelle ce public s'est élargi
ensuite parce qu'on a eu à faire face à
un flux de demandes avec des
institutions comme les musées les
bibliothèques les maisons de retraite
donc là on ne s'attendait pas maintenant
on doit être force de proposition
monotouch vous permet de vivre une
expérience originale conviviale
inédite ce n'est pas un projet figé dans
le temps elle est accessible elle est
résolument tourné vers l'avenir
elle vit qu elle propose bientôt de
nouveaux contenus immersif
[Musique]